body of my sister angela has been found
angela who is 50 had been living with
her husband james in tonga since getting
married
during their time in tonga they have
become well loved by both locals and
expats alike
james who is a highly skilled tattooist
had started a tattoo shop called the
happy sailor he employed local tongans
and taught them the skills needed to
become tattooists
angela has always had a deep love of
dogs and so started an animal welfare
charity called tours tonga animal
welfare society its aim was to provide
shelter and rehabilitation to stray dogs
before trying to find homes for them
i understand that this terrible
accident came about as they tried to
rescue their dogs
angela and james loved their life in
tonga and adored the tongan people in
particular they loved the tongan love of
family and tongan culture
from a little girl it was always
angela's dream to swim with wales and it
was tonga that gave her the opportunity
that allowed her to fulfill these dreams
as you can imagine her family is
devastated and we will respectfully
request that we are given privacy to
grieve
okay i'll take a couple of questions can
you tell us when was the last time uh
jennifer saw anger it would have been
about two years ago st her and james
came to the uk
um it was pre-covered and i think yeah
that was the last time any of us saw her
did they speak regularly when was the
last thing yes yeah they're constantly
in you know
zoom
calls we do three ways because i'm i
live in australia so mum anger and i
quite often would do three ways
which was always
pleasant you know hold your mom my
mother's 85
but i'm hesitating i think it might be
84 but
yeah so she's quite elderly
devastating for the whole family
the words can't i can't even haven't got
the words in my vocabulary to even
describe how
we're feeling at the moment this is just
a terrible shock
that's happened to us you know we're
we're ordinary people
stuff like this just doesn't happen to
people like us but then it does
do you have any idea what happens next
i have no idea but i i
believe that the consulate will arrange
i believe there's a process that we
would have to go through to
repatriate angela's body but i don't
know what that is and but we've just
basically just got to go through the
process
and um
you
take it where it where it goes
um and when did you get the news
confirmation the confirmation about um
six hours ago on the stop over in dubai
yeah any details
no other than um james had uh there's
been a search party that
had been going on and i believe james
but i'm not too sure
but i believe james found the body and
it was in some bushes
um i'm not really well
uh not really aware of the geography in
tonga other than it's a very sort of
low-lying scrubby sort of sandy area and
so you know yeah
she was probably found in that area
and can you just tell us what kind of
person
oh gosh
she's beautiful she was absolutely a ray
of sunshine um that um
she would walk into a room and just
lighten the room up and she
loved her life both when she was working
in london and then she achieved her life
stream of going to work in the south
pacific
um she always wanted to swim with wales
that was a childhood ambition and that
really is what drove her to
uh to tonga but she loved her life there
and we were so proud of
her achievements in such such a short
time in tong of both her and james
starting a business and and creating a
life there
and her charity work with tours um
you know i she was so committed to it
she loved
um animals and dogs particularly and you
know the uglier the dog the more she
loved it
and we would laugh at her
when she sent us photographs on facebook
of
of these these dogs that she'd rescued
that um
yeah just a lovely girl you could she's
the center of our family and you know we
we're just broken